hi steve kaufman here
i want to talk about the language
learning process and two i think very
important elements in that process first
of all
um i believe that we learn we don't know
which activities help us learn
as we're engaged in these different
learning activities we have no idea
how much is going to stick to if this is
the most effective way
to acquire the language
only after
weeks or months do we have a sense of
how much we achieve but while we're
actually engaged in the activity we
don't know it's not like we're shoveling
dirt from here to there or putting
things in a basket where we know that
we've taken five items moved them from
here and put them in
into some other location we just don't
know
uh and i so i'm just
talking about how i
sort of evaluate what i do
and and also refer to some of the books
that i've read and i feel that we need a
balance between
sort of interest stimulus novelty new
things
and
routine repetition
we need a balance of the two
the routine the repetitive activity is
in some ways easier to do
if you have a routine that every day at
10 o'clock you're going to review your
flash cards you'll do it how much that
gives you you don't know but it's
something
i find for example in my own case
talking about routine
i have a routine i get up in the morning
i go to certain websites
i download some articles in ukrainian i
import them in a link
and then i go through and i save all the
blue words if it says there's 20 new
words in our particular article i will
go through and look those words up and
save them to my database
that's done now that's a routine it's
it's an i don't have to think about it i
do it now i know that i have eight or
ten articles that i can read later on on
my ipad and when i read them of course
they will be interesting to me
uh i am interested
in the events in
ukraine and that's what's driving my
interest in learning the language
uh and so reading the articles is
interesting
i don't import everything sometimes now
i'm strong enough in my ukrainian that
i'll just read them it's only if there's
long articles with a lot of words that i
don't know or some key words that i
don't know that i imported so my
interest is driving me there two
uh
the repetition to uh as mountain fridge
spitzer in his book the brain and how he
learn things words to that effect said
we need a combination of repetition
which is where the neurons fire
you know
connections are created between neurons
which helps to retain things
uh we need a combination of that and
uh novelty and interest
but as robert bjork pointed out if we
just sit there and try to learn
something if we read the same list of
words over and over again or if we try
to remember say
an article on history
by the if we read deliberately you know
or study the list
three four five six times you reach a
point of diminishing returns after a
while it's not fresh any longer and he
points out that their research shows
that the process process of learning and
forgetting or what is called
interleaving in fact is more effective
so that you don't want to spend too much
time on repetitive
kind of routine tasks the routine task
though is
has the advantage you don't have to
think about it you just do it this is
what i do i get up in the morning i do
this for my ukrainian i think it's good
for me
but i'm now i have that habit so i do it
and it's good to have these habits
so um because i think the learning we're
not quite sure where it takes place and
so we have to kind of combine in my view
uh things of interest where you're
reading and listening and i do a lot of
listening to these articles where audio
is available which is often the case
and so these are my interest things i'm
listening to things even if i don't
fully understand it i'm reading things
even if i don't fully understand it even
if it's fuzzy
uh even if i keep on coming across the
same words that i've looked up before
and i still don't remember them it
doesn't matter because i'm i'm engaged
in this process of of interacting with
interesting material and at the same
time i do some of the routine things so
i think
if we have a process which combines the
interest
and and the routine
sort of the novelty and the repetition
that that will probably guarantee
progress
in the language even if we're never
quite sure
what the specific effect is of these
different learning activities i hope
that makes sense
be
interested in hearing your reaction bye
for now